the man charged with the murder of
conservative mp sir david amis appeared
in court amidst tight security
ali harbi ali a british national of
somali descent is also alleged to have
prepared for terrorist acts
ali was arrested shortly after the
attack on friday and for the last week
has been questioned by detectives
forensic teams also searched and removed
electronic devices from this property in
the capital
the suspect appeared at court one here
in westminster magistrates he was
wearing a grey track suit and black
glasses and spoke only to confirm his
name his age 25 and his address in north
london the hearing lasted just 13
minutes
before the hearing police renewed their
appeal for anyone with information to
come forward
we will continue to build our case
if there are members of the public who
have further information that might help
the investigation i would urge them to
come forward
every piece of information in
investigations like this is important
and you will not be wasting our time
please contact us through the
anti-terrorist hotline
sir david amis a veteran mp for south
end west was stabbed multiple times on
friday whilst holding a surgery for his
constituents in lyon sea
it's being treated as an act of
terrorism
the murder which has caused shock and an
outpouring of grief across this
community has also led to calls for
greater protection for mps
the threat to mps as the home secretary
said yesterday has been elevated a
little bit to substantial but that is in
line
with the general threat the terrorist
threat level in the country and
i think the police have done a fantastic
job of reaching out to mps telling them
what they need to do
to ensure their own safety and security
police say they're not looking for
anyone else in connection with the
attack
ali harby ali was remanded into custody
and will appear before the old bailey
tomorrow
alex rossi sky news central london